okay patrick mahomes is in a class of
his own as the quarterback of the kansas
city chiefs we saw what happened to the
chiefs and mahomes when they didn't have
eric fisher and mitchell schwartz
available on either end of the line of
scrimmage in super bowl 55. apparently
the chiefs looked at that and said we'll
take some more of that please because
that's where they are right now the
bloodletting continues in the nfl as the
salary cap drops from 198.2
to 182.5 when it would have been 208
this year so it's a 25 million decline
eric fisher cut mitchell schwartz cut by
the kansas city chiefs also senator
austin reiter expected to go elsewhere
in free agency
this is another example of what happens
in 2021 when you see revenue drop
dramatically salary cap drop
dramatically there's that thing that
teams do now thank you very much now
please leave hey we're we're firing this
guy today david thank you it's not a
retirement with a gold watch it's a get
the hell out of here it's a polite get
the hell out of here that's what they
did for mitchell schwartz and eric
fisher and i guess there's a chance they
could come back at a reduced salary
but they get thrown out into the pile of
veterans who aren't stars who are going
to find out that they're the ones miles
who are going to bear the brunt of the
pandemic losses from last year
no doubt and i you know what let me just
say this on these graphics i hate them
because at least personally if you ever
fire me do not put a graphic up on pft
saying it's already made
it's already made it's just a matter of
life just you better just no just wait
just wait give me my severance day and
let me get out like that's the thank you
that's all i want just the severance pay
and let me go hopefully that won't ever
happen or won't happen for a long long
time at least but i think the one thing
that makes this a little bit different
with kansas city is the injury situation
with both of those guys because you look
at schwartz he missed over half the
season with the back injury and they
kept talking about well maybe he can
come back maybe he might be able to come
back for the super bowl that didn't
happen eric fisher tears his achilles
during the afc championship game so who
even knows when he's going to be
available to play if he's going to be
able available to play in 2021 so i
think you know a few weeks ago mike we
were saying on this show hey man the
chiefs have got to be able to shore up
their backup situation and in this
particular case i almost feel like well
they're just saying let's rip the
band-aid off let's just go with the
whole rebuild of our offensive line
because frankly we won't necessarily be
able to rely on both of these guys for
being healthy in 2021 and as long as
we've got patrick mahomes we know that
our window is wide open so if that's the
case then let's just try to rebuild our
offensive line entirely i guess that's
just the approach they're taking what's
going to happen this offseason and
what's already happening now it's not
something that is unusual in that
it doesn't occur just doesn't occur to
this extent but it underscores the fact
that these football players on every
team are interchangeable parts now some
are more interchangeable than others
punters kickers it's very easy to say
we're removing one we're adding another
one because that person's performance
isn't dependent in any way on those
around him but even the guys like an
offensive line where ideally it works
five guys
in sync
even then even then
all of these players are
pieces of a machine
and at some point that piece gets
removed and a new piece gets put in
and they're constantly looking
for new pieces that would be cheaper and
or more effective than the pieces they
currently have that's what they do we've
talked about that before that jarring i
said magnets on the board you pointed
out it's actually all digital now but
however they do it
they're always looking they always have
the list of 10 left tackles 10 right
tackles 10 quarterbacks 10 guys at every
position that they would call if they
need someone and they have people who
are working behind the scenes to come up
with those lists studying film analyzing
contractual expectations
and this year more than any other miles
with all of these veterans out there who
will be available potentially at a
bargain basement price you're going to
have teams looking at their roster
looking at who's available and saying
hmm you know we've had this guy on the
team for eight years he's a great leader
he's a great part of the community but
the bottom line is dollar for dollar i
can get better value from one of these
veterans that was cut by another team so
i'm gonna do it and it's it's cold it's
dispassionate it is anything but
football is family
but
it shows you how the family business of
a football operation works guys get
ushered out the door all the time
with
if they're lucky
a social media graphic that says thank
you well and i think that what you were
pointing out earlier about the fact that
the cap is actually about 25 million
dollars lower than it was expected to be
in 2021 not just that it dropped from
last year that expectation is how teams
set up their their teams for years down
the road so if a team right now is
almost 20 million dollars over the cap
that means that they were not expecting
to be over the cap by that much or at
all at this point um in 2021 so
that i think has a lot to do with the
way teams are going to be constructed
for this upcoming season i think it's
going to be weird i think some guys who
are veterans are going to say you know
what just pay me a little bit and just
let me on this team and maybe we'll go
win a championship and i'll bet on
myself for the next year other teams
might just take the approach of we're
going to have a bunch of undrafted
rookies in here because i think about
the falcons and their team that does not
have that many contracts that they can
restructure they've got a quarterback
and a wide receiver who are very highly
paid they don't really have anybody that
many people on the roster right now
either so you're gonna have to probably
usher in a bunch of low paid veterans
and probably a bunch of undrafted free
agents and say hey man let's just get
out there and let's see what happens
let's see how good our coaching is let's
see how good our scouting department is
and let's just see what these guys can
do and that i think is going to happen
all over the league between the good
teams and the bad teams good teams
probably going to want these cheap
veterans bad teams to say let's just be
bad for this year and let's just weather
the storm and maybe in 2022 things will
be better
social media gives us plenty of bad
things it also gives us some good things
like footage from the future exclusive
footage of patrick mahomes
next season
lining up for the
kansas city chiefs that's kind of what
it was like in super bowl 55 and they
can't do much worse and part of it was
on them too 92 i think of the snaps were
just five guys
the five offensive linemen with no help
against that buccaneers defense so maybe
that maybe they'll keep a tight end in
once in a while or running back in once
in a while to help block for patrick
mahomes next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports